Tuesday thoughts as I go up the
escalator we get this writing right I
just can't believe how many of you don't
realize you're fundamentally in charge
like completely and utterly in charge
people dwelling and picking other people
controlling their lives
[ __ ] excuses to not do you are 100%
in charge and in control of your
circumstance you just got to break the
vortex if if you're not happy you just
got to break the game you're in you got
to break the box that you're stuck in
Miniver you've got a break [ __ ] cuz
you're in control nobody else so if you
see something we're doing you should
email us be like hey why did you rock do
that why'd you why'd you make it
Alexa briefing like you can you know
feel super comfortable and that all and
that out of all the things Alexa Alexa
turn off i mean jesus [ __ ] christ i
have to breathe deeply on two fronts
let me get novelistic do I believe in
the entrepreneur to do I believe in the
thesis and I and I've learned recently
that I can't waver I need to be a
hundred on both that's what I've worn
and any time I haven't been 100 on both
at long my intuition on pure intuition
is there's not a lot of people that know
me care about me and that we know that
are more wired into India so I'd really
like for you to to to build a
relationship I'd like to go to India in
late every way okay cool
okay thank you so much great down here
such a pleasure meeting you man yeah
what I really enjoyed it
[Music]
oh man hey VIN yeah man keep it well
yeah okay they're very real pleasure
strategy number one is sheer will the
the most important part of the strategy
is the part that nobody talks about
which is how fun is it to lay in bed
from 11:30 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
and type [ __ ] by your head cells one by
one and I'm very we're super fun I'm
about door I mean I looked at it too and
years ago now about to play with it as
well
a little bit like strategy super simple
here's the punchline I wrote about it in
2011 it's real simple I think you should
say hello to every single [ __ ] person
several listen new song leaders last
time last time looking at the 800
thousands and the other it's hard you
know it's really wild like I just
genuinely think it's about depth and
width and everybody only thinks about
with so when I like have somebody DMA me
like you're not gonna bask when I
[ __ ] you know a lot of times I'll
heart it they lose their mind but
sometimes I'm in the mood them like
thanks Karen in video reply which takes
like four seconds that I don't have
right uh well then she [ __ ] is a fan
for life
[Music]
intuitively and I was like it'll be fun
for him to come and like spend 20
minutes and educate me I'm like Gary no
no the reason I think YouTube is good or
why I think Nielsen's has a convert like
the things that I want to get to next
I'm a very you as you can tell hands off
for I like people calibrating auditing I
don't like putting them into like my
vision I like them to be independent
thinkers and taste and learn and I mean
the best part is you know we can't show
[ __ ] but in like 10 years we'll show at
all and it's going to bring people so
much value
[Music]
a lot of people ask is like when they're
trying to network in their teenager like
when you say now that we live in a world
where like you can access social we get
through our Facebook groups and that has
something to say
target that or Detailers in person video
stops oh I would use technology I mean
[ __ ] between the fact the technology is
now so respected that a 39 year old 52
year old seven year old will actually
respect you like when I was a kid
there's no 19 year old that had any
respect about business from anybody on
earth period ever any time ever yeah
so for entrepreneurs today they had such
an incredible situation one they have
the luxury that somebody might think you
get it because everyone's looking for
their Mark Zuckerberg and number two
you can get to anybody the [ __ ] are we
doing here yeah like right so like this
is not hatter
this is not happening you know 20 years
ago just want to be able to get to me
yeah I wouldn't you know they just not
how the world worked so no I think
everybody should I think whether you're
19 or 91 everybody should use technology
as a gateway drug to scale to meet I
having ever Li should spend I think
every single person is eight that is an
entrepreneur under 20 that wants to be
successful should hit their DM limit
every day DMing entrepreneurs or people
that they're interested in saying I'd
love to meet you what can I do for you
yeah
[Music]
my big advice to young people is to not
try to convince people to take them
serious I I think the best thing you
could do is when you're having that
conversation is tell them that if you
don't want to work with me and you're
not the work with me yeah you're saying
no for the other person a lot of times
is the quickest way for the other person
to say yeah yeah I'm trying to make not
as money in abundance talking about
twenty two fifties and hundreds and make
it after anything I know that it's
coming abandoned or soured the way of
the runners should know that I'm
destined for greatness
everyone always the aim everyone want to
be famous no but they want to be hated
I'm sick and tired of being Eastern face
but nobody say it's tough and the one
that's playing [ __ ] let's talk about
them famous as she watched on the behind
where others the player sees another
given you know that I'm making it why
don't one say and she why do I feel like
faking it don't even know either welcome
to baton this other part of the show
tell me it is I don't know that I'll
fill it no I don't spelling snow then
I'm Ellie
[Music]
this is what you came for is why you
paid for it up know it uh pretty
and I'm ready
[Music]
ready then I'm pretty tough yeah
whatever you say or this is what you pay
for
there's so much that's happening through
serendipity of learning I do think that
leaders take way too much onus on let me
fabricate these learnings when we are
moving fast
nobody even realizes what they're
learning here until they're like almost
out of it because we're stuck in a
vortex like people no real I were at the
forefront in such a meaningful way no no
no
[Music]
five thank you
[Music]
I told Tyler
I don't think that I'm a predictor I
think I'm a fast mover and so I don't
predict I have intuitive understanding
of consumer behavior and then I watch
what people are doing and I'm quickly on
it in a world where it's only 24 hours
and everybody has you know one of the
reasons I will break out in this era on
101 marketing I have more energy than
everybody else like you know it's
something that it's why don't get so
gassed on myself like I'm natural energy
like I can go hard forever like you know
and so like I think that that's not
replicatable for some people like people
take naps people need eight hours leave
people get tired like you know but I'm
so grateful and I'm so hungry then it
just [ __ ] makes me go through so I
think I think one of the things is the
biggest thing is if you're you know you
think about it like steps if you're like
on that next step now these guys are
there you know and then you'll have some
sort of you probably put out some song
that will be best song that takes it to
the next level right that it's about
being as hungry when you're getting
300,000 racks for a show and it's super
hard and it's like one of the people
who's like been able to get hungrier as
he's gotten richer more successful it's
obvious to me watching all my other
homies fall off when they get to that
place so what's really interesting is I
don't know if I can it's not about so
many different tactics it's about like
having a religious conversation like
there are certain things in people's
lives that they will never do I think
this question becomes what are your
lines in the sand you know like start
really digging deep into them it's not
self-awareness it's about how much do
you appreciate it how hungry are you at
it what comes natural what doesn't that
it's the framework for me I will never
line in the sand I will never ever
believe in my own [ __ ]
1:22 p.m. another grinding day super
hustle lots of results lots of meetings
the fast-paced day like very few days of
having the last year where I haven't
posted an Instagram all day between you
know like I love it enjoy it just
nothing like it when you're in that zone
[Music]